I'd like to now introduce our featured
presenter Matt Roth Matt is co-founder
of the feed collaborative at Stanford
University where he is an educated
educator practitioner in design thinking
and sustainable food system innovation
matt is also a lecturer in the Graduate
School of Business executive education
program where he frequently engages with
social entrepreneurs and executives
seeking to create social and
environmental impact in their work prior
to his career as a designer and teacher
Matt was fellow at the Stanford d.school
director of Stanford sustainable food
program and an Operations Executive at
both a tune and Niman ranch raised on a
10,000 acre conventional corn farm and
the plains of Colorado Matt's more
formal degrees include a BA in
environmental earth science from
Dartmouth College and an MBA from the
Graduate School of Business at Stanford
and with that let's turn it over to Matt
all right thank you very much Megan and
good morning to everyone out there it's
wonderful to see all of your smiling and
shiny faces this one so I'm looking
forward to the conversation today and I
think maybe they just get us started
I'll point out a couple things one is
that this the title here you're asking
the wrong questions at a high level what
we're talking about is that most people
when thinking about problems and
solutions often spend far more time and
thinking about whether or not they have
the right solution in mind and what
we've experienced over a decade of
working with entrepreneurs and
innovators in and around the food system
is that most most people in
organizations do not spend nearly enough
time really thinking about the problem
that they're trying to solve through the
work into the organization and so that's
what we're going to be spending our time
on today I teach at the design school
here and our goal is always to make the
teaching and learning that we do as
experiential as possible and I'm going
to attempt to do that today
and so what I'd like me to do is if you
have a blank sheet of paper and
something with which to write in your
vicinity I'm going to give you about a
minute to find that and if you don't
have something with which to write or
you're not in a place where you have a
piece of paper available to you but I
want you to do is just think about
I'm asking you here so in the next 60
seconds what I'd like you to do is to
identify an organizational problem on
which you're presently focused and I
want you to write that down on a piece
of paper or have it in mind and as
you're doing that I'd like for you to
frame it in the way that I've framed
these examples here which is the problem
is that and then fill in the blank to
that and so I've given you a range of
examples here of things that people are
often thinking about problems that
they're trying to solve in the course of
their work so I'll give you 60 seconds
right now to write the problem that you
presently focused on in your
organization and then we're gonna come
back and we're gonna move forward okay
here we go so I'm gonna start by talking
a little bit about my background as a
way to set up how I've gotten here and
what you see here's a picture of me and
my dad on a combine on this day we were
combining corn and our ten thousand acre
farm on eastern plains of Colorado and I
mentioned this because as I was
approaching graduation from my
undergraduate degree I called up my dad
and having thought a lot about what I
wanted to do for a career afterwards and
it occurred to me that farming was
really what I wanted to do and so I
called him up and I asked him if I could
come back and form with him and I
proposed because at the time organic was
kind of taking off in the marketplace
and I saw there's an opportunity for our
farm I proposed to my dad that we begin
to convert to organic farming and then I
come back and help him do that and I
wasn't prepared for the response of
Gabey the response was sorry son we can
do neither of those and I think we were
both disappointed by that response but
what he explained to me were a couple of
problems with our agriculture which I
which I'm showing you here the first one
is that with respect to organic you know
from his mind you know the problem is
that farmers need to meet the
nutritional demands of a growing
population and he just didn't see a way
for organic to do that at the time and
then the second problem that he
identified for me was this problem that
with farming is that the consolidation
is
it really hard to pass farms along to
the next generation
and so really for me this instigated
that career and really trying to think
about and solve these problems and what
I'm going to share with you today is the
some of my experience and thinking about
these problems and where we're at in
terms of working on these today and the
work that we're doing now more
importantly to think about and share
with yous and tools that I've developed
along the way that I think will be
useful to you in your organization's as
you're thinking about problems that
you're facing today and you've
identified just now so I think to set
this up I want to share a few kind of
key learning moments for me along the
way in terms of how I got to be doing
what I'm doing now and the first one was
really my initial job out of school
working at Mountain Ranch where in the
course of the six years I worked there
we were able to move from supporting 50
small family farmers to five hundred and
if for me that became a real example of
how we can scale sustainable agriculture
which I then took into business school
here with the mindset of really trying
to understand better the economics of
farming and how we might rethink
economic relationships between buyers
and sellers and then unfortunately in
the second year of Business School my
dad was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer
and which is a essentially a year-long
death sentence why would you turn out to
be but in that and they year I ended up
helping my dad manage my farm and then
helping my mom and selling the farm
after he passed away and there were a
couple of really critical moments and
that experience as terrible as it was
that really redefined how I think about
problems generally and especially within
agriculture and I want to share with you
at this moment that occurred for me
it's so after my dad passed away as we
were dealing with a real estate agent to
sell the farm he had asked me if I could
take a look at my dad's yields as a way
to put about you or help put a value on
the farm and so I got into his files and
I found a graph that looks not unlike
this one that was
demonstrating the yields of corn over
the course of our the history of our
farm and what you see here is is more or
less approximately what I had seen which
was steadily increasing yields over time
and from the perspective of valuing the
farm this was very helpful because it
suggested that the farm was increasing
in its value over time and so later that
afternoon so I was looking at this in
the morning
later that afternoon we met with the
real estate agent out on the farm to
show him around give him the tour and
I'll never forget it was such a poignant
moment for me that I took a picture of
it and this is the picture that I took
and so we're sitting on a hill
overlooking one of the the center-pivot
irrigation circles on our farm and this
was in like June or July and it was
after what had been the most rain that
we'd received in the spring in recorded
history I believe and we are in a short
short grass prairie region which is
effectively a desert we get less than 10
inches of rain a year and so it's really
unusual to see the kind of meaning that
we're seeing here and it was a really
magnificent sight but I was struck by
the just position of that with the
circle that you see there on the left
which is brown and all sensibly dead and
we went down and we took a closer look
at it and this is a picture of that farm
this is a sensibly where we are growing
food and I was just struck by the fact
that there is there was nothing growing
here and I'm pretty confident that we
had sprayed to kill everything but what
I noticed was that the soil on this
field was just devoid of life of any
kind and so in my mind you know as I was
looking at this graph earlier in the day
realizing what seemed to be an
increasing productivity of the farm and
then actually going out and seeing it in
the state it really occurred to me that
something is fundamentally wrong here
and I made me think of this problem that
my dad had mentioned as being kind of
the fun
problem or agriculture was that farmers
need to meet the nutritional demands of
a growing population and it struck for
me this question is is this the right
problem to be solving to the extent that
we are doing to the soil what we appear
to be doing and so that launched me on
to this path that I am now and really
rethinking how we approach our
agriculture I want to just demonstrate
you the challenge that we face in
thinking about problems and one is what
a little demonstrate here and that none
of us growing up as kids in school were
ever asked the question who knows the
right problem the question almost always
is who has the right answer and so from
our very beginnings we are patterned on
this idea that there is one problem and
one solution and this continues into our
culture in our work environment so I'm
demonstrating an example here this would
feel absurd I think to most of us if
anyone asked us the question that's
presented here and the reality is that
we operate in organizations where we are
incentivized to design brilliant
solutions and we are not incentivized to
design brilliant problems now I think
that this quote from Einstein really
sums up why this matters and I'll just
read it out loud here the formulation of
a problem is often more essential than a
solution which may be nearly a matter of
mathematical or experimental skill to
raise new questions new problems to read
or regard old problems from a new angle
the correct requires creative
imagination and March real advance in
science and I think that most people
generally would believe this to be true
and I certainly have in the time that
I've been working on this and what my
son is really talking about here is what
is the the language that we use of
reframing problems but the question I
think that most people run into is yes I
understand the value of that but how do
I do that and that's what we spent the
last
six to seven years really thinking about
and developing tools to help people do
this I think it's worth mentioning here
that our approach to this as Megan
mentioned earlier has been through the
lens of educators and practitioners of
design thinking and innovation and in in
that practice our practice is to borrow
tools and techniques from many different
disciplines and to think about how we
might use them in an applied way that
are designed to be as useful to the
people using them as possible and so our
lens really is in making tools for
people to use and in this case I'm going
to share some of those tools that we use
I should also note that we are not
traditional academics and that we don't
do research on this stuff we often look
at research and borrow what we see is
being tools that we can convert for
people to use like you and I also say
that there is a fair amount of
literature out there around problem
definition problem solving and I'm
guessing that some of this will be
familiar to those of you who work in
those fields and if I haven't cited the
reference to your work I would love to
hear from you
I would love to read what you've
produced as a way to better inform the
things that we're doing okay so the the
one tool going to start with
demonstrating today is this idea of
reframing problems by identifying
causality and constraints around a
problem and the way that I'm going to do
this is by way of telling a story and
the story comes from an article that was
written in the Harvard Business Review I
think five or six years ago it's cited
at the end of these slides and I'll show
this to you but basically the story is
of a building manager and the building
were in time in the mid-1950s when
building televator technology was
advancing rapidly and so a lot of people
in the city were experiencing these
elevators that were much faster we're
becoming much faster
and as a result of that the occupants
antennas in his building began to
complain about the speed of the elevator
and their bill and so originally the
building manager defined the problem as
this one here the problem is that people
are complaining about the speed of the
elevator and so originally the building
manager was thinking about this and
immediately jumped to thinking about
solutions to this problem and as with
most people the first ones that come to
mind are obvious solutions to this
problem and a few he came to mahadba
came to mind for him where did that
maybe the elevator needed a faster motor
maybe there was a new or better
algorithm to make the elevator more
efficient and another option another
potential solution was just put in a new
elevator altogether but the building
manager really started to think about
this and the question he asked himself
was what might be the the causes of this
problem and so what he did is he created
a list on a piece of paper just like the
one that you haven't found you and the
potential causes that he identified for
this were an obvious one here the
elevator maybe isn't working properly he
had noted that new elevators and other
buildings are becoming faster so maybe
that's a part of the problem of people
complaining and then the third one here
which I thought was pretty interesting
is this 18 just this potential cause
that he identified well maybe is that
people don't have anything to do while
they wait and so we're gonna come back
to that one but in thinking about the
causes of the problem this is what he
had come up with so then he got to
thinking about well okay if I'm gonna
begin solving these problems certainly
I'm going to be working with some
constraints and so the next thing that
he did was he asked himself himself you
know what are the constraints that I
might encounter in solving this problem
and a couple that he came up with were
those listed here which is well we don't
really have a budget for a new elevator
so we need to get new funding to do that
and in terms of making the elevator the
existing elevator more efficient there
were not better algorithms on the market
to help him do that
and I think what was really interesting
about this example is that she realized
that he could turn all of these causes
and all these constraints into problems
themselves which you can see listed here
and as he was thinking about this he had
this sort of aha moment in the aha
moment was that I can choose which of
these problems to solve and I think this
is an important moment in illustrates
the point I made earlier which is that
for the first time he realized that he
had agency here to actually define the
problem right
he started with this original problem
that people are complaining about the
speed of the elevator but by identifying
the actual causes or potential causes of
that problem thinking through the
constraints and trying to solve the
problem and then reframing them as
problems ok this moment of realizing
that there are more than one problem to
be solved here and that he can choose
which one to do so but then the question
was which one should I choose and as he
was thinking about this he was trying to
think through all of the potential
questions and things that he would need
to think about in deciding which one to
choose and he came up with a list of
things the first one was for which of
these problems do I have the right
leverage or influence the thicker one
was for which do I have the right
abilities and competencies like can I do
this or not do I have the knowledge or
skills the third one was for which one
do I have the right resources do I have
enough money or time to be able to solve
this problem another one was if I try to
solve a constraint in particular how do
I make sure that I'm not just amplifying
the cause of the problem to the extent
that he's not focusing in on what
there's perceived to be the actual
causes of this problem people
complaining about the elevator to aim
too slow and then the last one was I
think this is a really critical one what
are the potential under tended
consequences of solving each of these
problems and so he went through
the list of all the problems that he had
identified and was thinking through this
list of questions that he had and so the
first one was the problem is that the
elevator isn't working properly and so
he immediately diagnosed the elevator it
turned out that it was working fine so
that was not the problem he took a look
at the problem is the elevator or that
new elevators and other buildings are
becoming much faster but he realized
that he didn't really have any leverage
or influence in changing that and so
that wasn't apparently a very good
problem for him to tackle he took a look
at the problem is that people don't have
anything to do while they wait and on
this one he thought to himself well I
may or may not had the right abilities
or resources but I'm not sure he didn't
took a look at the the constraints as he
had turned them into problems and the
problem is that we don't have a budget
for a new elevator and as he thought
about this the question that came to
mind was well if we raise rents to buy a
new elevator might actually draw more
attention to the elevator itself and so
it seemed to him there might be an
unattended consequence here of actually
trying to fix the elevator and then the
last one the problem is that the better
algorithms don't yet exist he thought to
himself well I don't have the right
abilities to design a better algorithm
but if I did I might just be creating
this sort of like this idea of a
reinforcing feedback loop of having to
always have the fastest elevator and so
he would kind of get stuck in this trap
of having to always be solving this
problem and so as he stepped back and he
took a look at all these problems that
he identified potential problems that he
could begin or the historical trying to
solve the one that he identified was
this one which is the problem is that
people don't have anything to do while
they wait and so he as he was thinking
about trying to solve this problem he
did some research and what he discovered
was that there's actually a lot of work
done around what's known as queueing
theory and if you ever go to Disneyland
or a large amusement park they spend a
lot of time thinking about how to
entertain people while they're waiting
right and what he discovered in that
research was that if you install mirrors
around the elevator as you can see here
people will be happy to wait if they
have time to look at themselves to print
themselves and to look at how beautiful
they are and so I think that this is a
really beautiful example of how
reframing problems in this way really
thinking about what are the real causes
of the problem that I'm starting with
what are the constraints around trying
to solve that problem thinking through
those questions around which ones are do
have the abilities and competencies
through these sources to solve can lead
to really easy elegant solutions and the
point of all of this the underlying
reason why this works in terms of
innovation is this reframing problems
helps us get away from the obvious
solutions right so had he only focused
on the original problem of people
complaining about the speed of the
elevator he would have likely invested
in a new motor maybe a new control
algorithm or maybe he would have
purchased a new elevator all together
but by reframing that original problem
what he was able to do was to define a
new problem and that led to less obvious
solutions which for him were mirrors
around doors and what you see here is a
representation a representation of the
potential solution set that's related to
how we define a problem and in this case
by reading reframing the problem he was
able to open up a number of potential
solutions and when you do that it
becomes just a math equation and that
you have many more potential solutions
to draw from and solving the problem
this is really critical to how we think
about leading to or finding creative
solutions innovative solutions to
existing problems so what I want you to
do now is to take a look at the problem
that you've identified or to come back
to it in your head if you think if you
thought about our original
as you're thinking about this problem
what I want you to realize is that this
problem and every problem is caused by
something else this problem and every
problem is constrained by something and
importantly these causes and constraints
to be reframed as other problems and as
as you're thinking about your problem I
would encourage you either now or
afterwards to think about how you might
do this I think it's really important to
remember that reframing problems often
leads to unexpected and innovative
solutions I think that the mirrors
around the elevator a great example of
this but then the work that we've done
we've seen hundreds of examples of this
happening that we see it every day in
the classes that we teach here and I
think it's important as you're doing
this to beware of unintended
consequences when solving for
constraints I'm going to talk a little
bit about this later on but often when
we try to solve for constraints we are
either solving for time and money or for
new technologies and the challenge of
solving for time and money is that from
our experience it often really limits
the potential solution set and so it
doesn't allow you to get to really
creative innovative solutions and a
challenge with using new technology to
solve constraints which in my experience
of working with a lot of organizations
is often the direction that they had is
that it's really difficult when solving
for a constraint to be unaware or not
think about the potential unintended
consequences that might result from that
technology we see this all the time
where new technologies simply amplify
the underlying cause of the problem that
we're trying to solve I'm going to use
an example later to make that point and
then the last thing as you're thinking
about this problem that you have is the
the second aspect of what I want to
share with you today
and it's this idea of always being
mindful of human needs as we're thinking
about reframing and defining problems
and I'm gonna spend a little time
talking about that now
and I think that this is probably the
best image that I have found to describe
what I see hundreds of times with
organizations and this is true of
entrepreneurial startups to established
industry players that have been around
for a long time and the reality that I
see is that most organizations tend to
focus on the needs of the organizations
and not squarely or specifically on
these are their customers clients their
service recipients their students in
some cases and so the goal of defining
problems is to make sure they're to be
aware of the fact that this exists
pretty frequently and to align these two
things in ways that solve both needs and
so I wanna run through an example of
what this looks like and how to do this
so I have a question for you and as
you're looking at this picture the
question is what does this girl need and
I want you to just think about that for
a couple seconds now if you're like most
of the students in our classes and most
of the executives at the business school
where I teach the first couple things
that come to mind is that she needs a
book or that she needs a ladder and the
question that I want to ask of you is
why does she need a book and why does
she need a ladder and most often the
answer to why does she need a book is
she needs a way to learn I think that
this is important this is what we refer
to as a needs ladder and in design as we
think about needs our goal is to
identify both the explicit and the
implicit needs that people have and so
in this case the explicitly would be a
book or a ladder whereas the implicit
need would be that she needs a way to
learn this is really important
again in terms of defining problems to
maximize the potential for innovative
and creative solutions and I want to
show you again why that is so in this
example the obvious or explicit need
that most people identify in that
example is that she needs a ladder or a
block but if we open up the question to
her need as being a way to learn what
that does is it opens up the total
potential solution set right there are
many potential solutions to a way to
learn for her whereas a lot of book are
very specific solutions and again this
is an example of how by identifying
these implicit needs we're able to just
open up the potential solution set and
what that does is offers an opportunity
to identify truly innovative new
creative ways of solving problems for
people now there's another aspect of
this it's important to keep in mind and
this is a picture of Maslow's hierarchy
with which some of you are probably
familiar I think those of you who are
familiar with it know that in psychology
this has become a defunct way of
thinking about psychology and people but
for our purposes is actually really
useful and the reason that is useful is
that it is a pretty fair representation
of moving from explicit needs which in
this case are more like physiological
needs around food breathing water
towards moving up to more implicit needs
that people have around social
psychological and emotional needs and
the value of this is that what we know
from a lot of experience and from a lot
of demonstration is that if you're able
to frame a problem that incorporates an
implicit or social emotional or
psychological need of a person or of
people and to design a solution for that
need you're far more likely to design
something that that person will actually
want to use and as we think about
innovation getting new people to try new
things this is a really critical aspect
of driving the innovation and through
a problem definition okay so I want to
come back to the example of the building
manager and the problems that he
identified having moved through
identifying the causes and the
constraints and joining those in the
problems what you'll note here is that
the one that he chose focused on people
now this is coincidental to a certain
extent but I think it's a great way of
illustrating the example or the point
that I'm making here and so what I want
you to do now is to take a look at the
problem that you've identified and what
I'd like you to do is to ask yourself if
you haven't already involved people in
some way in in the definition of the
problem is how could you reframe this
problem to involve people in some way
how could you identify an explicit need
here which is to say what do these
people need to be able to do that's part
of the definition of your problem and
then the last one this is really
critical is that you're thinking about
defining or reframing this problem how
can you reframe the problem in the way
that identifies a need through the
people in this problem to feel and I
think that in my experience of working
with students and executives but this is
probably the most critical aspect of
thinking about how to define problems if
we can't or aren't able to identify and
solve for needs that people have in this
regard it's very unlikely that the
solutions were going to develop will be
adopted or desired by the people for
whom we're designing but I want to
believe with kind of the story of the
work that we've been doing as a way to
illustrate I think what I have come to
see is the most important thing around
problem definition and so I mentioned
earlier this tension between this
problem that our agriculture is trying
to solve which is the problems that
farmers need to meet the nutritional
demands of a growing population yet at
the same time we're seeing our farmland
end up
looking like this we're effectively
destroying the soil and I want to tell a
story a personal story to help
illustrate I think what is it the
fundamental challenge of this note that
I think exists within many industries
and sectors so this is a picture of me
and my grandpa when I was young and my
grandpa was fond of telling this story
although I never I never heard it my dad
actually told it to me when he was sick
and the story is how the tractor ruined
farming in the story is basically he
goes like this originally the the
primary technology on our farms were
horses and and that was fine we wake up
in the morning we feed the horses we
feed ourselves we saddle them up we take
him out we'd work until noon and we'd
come back we'd eat and then we go back
and work in the afternoon until either
we couldn't work anymore or the horses
couldn't work anymore
and then one day the tractor was
invented and the the promise of the
tractor was amazing it was gonna make a
lot of money for farmers it was gonna
save us a lot of time we were gonna be
happier and so we bought a tractor and
everything was great the tractor was
definitely more efficient but we didn't
realize a couple things in buying the
tractor and one was that this tractor
required maintenance
it required fuel and as farmers we
didn't have a ton of money on the
balance sheet and so we had to borrow
money we had to take out an operating
long - just to run the tractor and that
was on top of a loan that we had to take
out to buy the tractor and so that was
fine but what we realized was that this
tractor was actually so productive that
we didn't have enough farmland to
actually make it pay for itself and so
what we had to do was we had to buy more
land just to make the tractor pay for
itself and so as a result of that we
took out another mortgage we bought more
land and we started form farming
efficiently and finally we were able to
pay off the tractor and for a short
period of time this was great we were
making a little bit more money we were
definitely more efficient
but what happened was that everybody
started buying tractors and everybody
was buying more land and everybody was
producing more food and in a short
period of time as a result of that with
more food on the market the price of
that food began to decline for consumers
this was great but for farmers this
wasn't so great what it meant was that
from moving from the horses to tractors
we had taken on a bunch of debt and at
the end of the day because of falling
food prices we weren't any better off
economically and as my dad was telling
me this story I realized that this was
an allegory for pretty much every
technology that has been developed in
our agriculture since and it's all been
in service of this question of how are
we going to feed all of these people in
this growing population and so when I
saw our farm looking like this that was
the moment when I realized I think that
we're solving the wrong problem here and
when you think about what is the real
problem that we're trying to solve I was
notified of this this fact a couple of
years ago and it really struck me and
I've reframed it here the problem is
that the United Nations Food and
Agriculture Bus remaining before we're
unable to feed everyone and this is
largely a result of the way that we farm
and by literally destroying the soil on
which we rely to grow food it's clear to
me through my experience that the
problem we're trying to solve is the
wrong problem and I think what I've
learned is that the solution to this
generally speaking this is true of this
problem and it's true that the problem
you have in front of you is that the
solution is to solve the causes of these
problems and to solve the implicit needs
of people and I'm confident based on all
of our experience in the work that we're
doing and through many examples of
thought leaders and others and the food
system who are doing this that if we
begin to think this way and frame our
problems in this way
that we truly have an opportunity to
solve some of these deeply systemic
issues that we face or whatever the
sectors and industries are that we
operate and I'm hoping that by way of
today that this gives you some tools for
you to do this within your
organization's
and it gives you some power to reframe
these problems in ways that will result
in positive outcomes for people in our
planet and I think that's all that I've
got for today great thank you very much
Matt for this very informative
presentation and I hope that all of you
have spent some time rethinking the
organizational challenge you wrote down
in the very beginning of Matt's
framework and ideas okay so I'm seeing
that we have a few questions along the
same theme so I will make sure to
propose that one first so people are
asking about you know finding you know
talking about finding the problem
identifying the problem and so to sum up
several of these different types of
questions people would first like to
know what kind of preparation or legwork
should they be doing before they feel
like they're ready to identify the real
problem is there any anything that they
should should do yeah no I think you
know as we thought about these tools I
think the real value of them is that
they can be applied today to whatever
the problem is that you're working on
and this could be we've done this with
teams and with executives who
encountered problems on a daily basis
recurring problems it could be in a
strategic setting so it is really
designed as a way to think about
whatever the problem is that's in front
of you whether it's something that's
happened that you didn't expect or
whether this is something that you're
thinking about long-term worship teach
eclis and so so really the preparation
is just wherever you're at begin there
great and would you say so this is the
other side of the question that's gotten
would you say that's the same
if you're trying to find kind of the
cause of a consumer problem so if you
look at it the other way not internal
but the external identifying their
problems yeah for sure
and I think so there I guess there are a
couple things around that one is we and
this gets into another aspect of design
thinking that I haven't touched on today
Design Thinking is also known as human
centered design and what that really
means is that if you're thinking about
how to design something where there's a
product or service or experience for a
consumer or a customer or a client or
somebody external to the organization we
we often believe that we both know what
their problem is and what the solution
is to that and that's a fundamental
assumption that needs to be challenged
and the way to challenge that assumption
is by actually talking to your customers
your clients and your customers to
identify what are the real both explicit
and implicit needs that they have and
then determine that learning into what
you think that the problem is now I'll
see and I think this is really critical
in every aspect of thinking about
problems is that when we define a
problem I think the best way to think
about it is as a hypothesis and not as
the you know a set in stone statement of
what we think the problem is you know we
are inferring what we think the problem
is and in design what we teach is to
think about that problem as a hypothesis
to develop some ideas or concepts that
we think might solve the neter problem
that we've identified and to test that a
bunch of times as a way to both refine
the framing of the problem based on what
we're learning through the testing the
experimentation as well as to understand
is this idea of solving than me that
we've identified or not and I think that
there's a lot of value to doing that
first of all it ensures that the problem
that you're focusing on is a real
problem to be solved that people have
these real needs and it also saves a lot
of time and money before investing a lot
of money into what we think of as being
the solution to the problem only to
realize once it's been out in the market
that nobody actually wants it and we
refer to this pretty frequently as
technologies and serve and search of a
need and we see this all the time here
in Silicon Valley that I've been a part
of a start-up for which that was the
case as well so several people are also
asking so once a problem has been
identified and properly framed is there
a certain thought process in identifying
the steps towards the solution yeah so
once you have a problem in mind I think
the most important thing is to think
about it as a hypothesis and in terms of
moving towards solution what we
recommend is in what we practice and
this is this is a core to design
thinking is to develop a number of
potential solutions to that problem
right and so the relationship between
problem definition as I mentioned
earlier and the potential solution set
is really important so if you've got the
right framing is going to open up the
potential solution set what that really
means is that there are a lot of
potential solutions in that the goal is
to identify as many of those as possible
and then to create a way to think about
which of them is likely to solve the we
have which do we have the resources
available to pursue which of them are
really creative and innovative which of
them might or might not create
unintended consequences if we're
thinking about bringing them to life and
then to before again before taking those
ideas from that from that potential set
to do some very early testing of those
ideas and we literally do those on
pieces of paper in front of the people
for anymore solving just to get a sense
of is this idea good or not is this
really that we've identified or the
problem that we're trying to solve and
then doing that many times in an
iterative way to get to a place where we
feel like that idea or solution concept
is really meeting the need or solving
the problem that we've identified great
so people are also asking a lot of
questions about hidden and implicit
needs and identifying those yeah so do
you have any techniques for really
discovering these especially if it's a
society that perhaps has poor
communication or you don't have the the
same type of accesses you know some of
the companies in Silicon Valley may have
to do people at serving yeah so what I
would say is generally speaking there
are a lot in a global context there are
a lot there are many constraints around
using the techniques that we use in
design to uncover the implicit needs
that people have
I want the hours of conversation to
explain those but in in our context the
goal of I did how to identify the
implicit needs that people have it's
really under trying to understand what
they care about and what motivates them
and the simplest way to put that is to
understand why people say what they say
in response your to a question that you
might ask there's an expression of five
why's to cry and that experiment that
expression is rooted in this idea that
if you ask somebody why - the same
question it can be same question and
answer you will eventually get into this
thing that they most deeply care about
and the goal in having conversations
with our customers or clients or service
recipients and our students is really to
understand at that level like what do
they really care about and that helps to
provide insight into the context of
whatever the problem is that you're
trying to solve whether that's a product
or a service or some kind of experience
great so I think we have time for maybe
one or two more so people are asking
about root cause analysis yeah
specifically if it differs from problem
identification or are they essentially
the same you know
I'll answer that in two ways one is that
as I mentioned I'm not an academic and
so we pull and we also pull from a lot
of different disciplines I'm familiar
with root cause analysis but I'm not an
expert in it but as I know it's
effectively to my mind essentially the
same thing that really understand you
identifying what is the root cause of
the problem that we're working on and I
know that there are a lot of tools and
techniques and processes that people use
in that discipline to do that and I
think that that's a great source of
information of thinking about you know
working with this problem that I have
and using those tools from that
discipline to identify whether the
causes might be so the last one that I
think we'll have time for so a lot of
people are I think trying to figure out
how to reframe their own their own
questions and challenges so perhaps we
could answer most of these types of
questions if you could talk about how
you reframed the you know this issue of
meeting nutritional needs of a growing
population like how how did you reframe
that yeah that's a great question so in
a couple of ways one is that I see the
problem
so we I've reframed that problem as the
problem is that we need to maximize the
productive capacity of our soils and
that takes into account what we are
actually doing to our soils which is
diminishing their viability of the long
term and it's also inclusive of this
problem that we need to maximize
productivity in order to produce food
for this growing population
so we've reframed it in that way to be
inclusive of both of those problems
there's a separate problem that we've
reframed in a way on to identify people
and their implicit needs and the the
question that we that I often ask of
entrepreneurs and people who are working
in food specifically or or in
agriculture
is how can we grow produce sell and
consume food that unlocks the potential
of humans and I like that one because it
really reframes food as being just
calories that eat people to food as
being tools really unlock and tap into
the potential of people and I think by
thinking about it that way it just
really reframes like how do you think
about the utility of in a very different
way and I think it begins to get at or
encompass some of the really terrible
problems that were existing that exists
in the system respectively and people
around these skyrocketing obesity rates
that we're seeing rates of type 2
diabetes that exist today the inequities
in the system that leads you a billion
people on the planet either starving or
being malnourished and so I think that I
think that if we can solve that problem
we will be going a focus on that as
being a long way in designing a food
system that actually has people at its
center and that is trying to make
premise healthy productive and to help
them realize their potential negative
possible great so thank you so much and
thank you everyone for submitting
submitting your questions unfortunately
we're getting close to the hour so we'll
have to wrap the queue a thank you so
much Matt for sharing your knowledge and
your and thank you for to our
participants for today those of you who
have indicated an interest in the
program our team will be reaching out
with more information and you can always
visit us at global impact stanford.edu
thanks all for joining us today and have
a great rest of your week
you